now let me enter the the ones that I can
quickly get out of the way quickly get
out of the way okay are you ready let's
deal with Jesus praying to God if Jesus
Is God how can he pray to God was he
praying to himself you ready that's very
simple if you know your Bible and you
know what you're supposed to believe
Jesus is praying to the father Jesus is
not the father Jesus is not the father
now if Jesus is not the Father and Jesus
is not the Holy Spirit and these are
three eternally distinct
persons
who commune with one another have
fellowship with one another are in love
with one another then why would it
surprise you that Jesus would be praying
to the father if he's not the father but
he's distinct from the father and yet in
relationship to the father in communion
with the father in fellowship with the
father and in love with the father
because prayer doesn't simply mean
worship and this is where you guys get
yourselves in
trouble prayer doesn't simply mean
worship biblically prayer can
mean
communion
communication right intimate Fellowship
right can also mean invoking
asking and it can mean
worship so why would it surprise you
that Jesus who is not the father but the
father's Divine son would pray to the
father in the sense that he'd speak to
the father he would have intimate
fellowship with the father he would have
communion with the father when that's
what you should expect to find if Jesus
is not the same person as the father but
he's Inseparable from the father as his
beloved Son who's in love with the
father who's always having intimate
communion and fellowship with the
father now if my definition of prayer is
correct if my definition of prayer is
correct again I need you to listen if my
definition of prayer is correct that
it's not simply worship it's also
intimate
communion intimate
Fellowship intimate
conversing then we would expect to find
the father praise to the Son and the
spirit and the son prays to the father
and the spirit and the spirit prays to
the father and the
son you got it Joseline you just took
the words out of my mouth and the
thought out of my mind I even said that
on Discord when I answer answer this for
someone yesterday on Discord I go if you
guys restrict the meaning of prayer
you're going to destroy your doctrine of
the communion of saints because that's
one of the arguments Protestants level
against this Doctrine how can you
worship the Saints and he said well we
don't worship them yeah you do you pray
to them assumption prayer is
worship so Jon God bless you with that
sharp mind Lord bless you
Sister now if my definition of prayer is
correct that it's intimate fellowship
and communion where the members of the
godhead lavish love on one another
praise for one another are engag in
Intimate communion and and fellowship
with one another guess what we should
expect to find the other members of the
godhead also praying to the others and
lo and behold I'm going to show
you where the father prays to the
son you ready
I'm going to show you where the father
prays to the son because what is prayer
what did I say intimate communion and
fellowship where you lavish praise and
glory and express love to the
other if if my definition is right then
we should expect to find the father and
the spirit also engaged in prayer and
guess what we find Mark 111 let's unpack
the meat Mark 111
no not Psalm 27 that yeah you can use
that but there's a little difficulty
that because Tech yeah you can yeah but
yeah all right just let's go to Mark 111
then a voice Came From Heaven you are my
beloved Son in whom I'm well pleased
here the father prays to the son I.E he
communicates to the son and he expresses
his love for the son saying son you are
my beloved and I am well pleased with
you now let's go to Hebrews 1:
8-12 not Matthew 3:17 no Mark 1:1 keep
it simple my
brother Hebrews 1
18-12 okay now read with me but to the
son he the father says guys watch but to
the son he the father says to the son
your throne oh God is forever and ever a
sep of righteousness is the sep of your
Kingdom you have loved righteousness and
hated lawlessness therefore God your God
has anointed you with the oil of
gladness more than your companions and
you Lord now this is the father speaking
to the son praying to the son glorifying
the son praising the son magnifying the
son so what does the father say to the
son you Lord in the beginning laay the
foundation of the earth and the heavens
are the work of your hands they will all
perish but you remain and they will all
grow old like a garment like a cloak you
will fold them up right you will fold
them up verse 12 now notice what he says
in 12 and they will be changed but you
are the same and your years will not
fail do you understand that should
really rock you and move you to the core
of your being if God the Father Almighty
himself glorifies the son magnifies the
son praises the son
lavishes praise and glory upon the
son as his way of expressing his
infinite love for the son and uses
language for the son that you cannot use
for a creature notice what the father
said to the son you are The God Who
reigns forever you are the Lord who
created the heavens and the Earth you
sustain them you roll them up you my son
are more exalted than your companions
you my son are perfectly righteous and
hate evil you my son remain the same
forever that's
prayer now can I show you the Holy
Spirit
praying can I show you the Holy Spirit
praying yeah in the Greek the word for
God is O oos haos Romans 8:26-27 Romans
8:26 to
27 pay
attention Romans 8:26 to
27 likewise the spirit also helps in our
weaknesses for we do not know what we
should pray for as we ought but the
spirit himself makes intercession for us
with groanings which cannot be uttered
now watch this
right now he who searches the hearts God
the father knows what the of the spirit
is because he the spirit makes
intercession for the Saints according to
the will of God you understand what you
just read it's the Holy Spirit who
teaches you how to pray moves you to
pray and puts in your heart what to say
because he's the one praying through you
to the father in accord with the
father's will
you got it now is it sinking in before I
move
on see confirmation Latino I'm
proud so does Jesus pray yes does the
Holy Spirit pray yes does the father
pray yes so if Jesus can't be God
because he prays then the father can't
be God because he prays and only Spirit
can't be God because he prays you see
how silly this
is and and part of prayer includes
glorifying God right praising God right
magnifying God
right okay did the father not glorify
the son in Hebrews magnify the son in
Hebrews praise the son in
Hebrews now let me show you what the
Holy Spirit does let me show you what
the Holy Spirit does John 16 14-
15 John 161 14-5
see your Bible is Supernatural your
Bible is divine your Bible is truly the
perfect word of God and it's the voice
of the true God who truly exists who is
real who's alive but you got to know the
Bible now notice here John 161
14-5 John 161
14-5 Jesus speaking of the Holy Spirit
the spirit of Truth he will glorify me
end of story there you go he will
glorify me
so what do you do in prayer glorify God
what does the Holy Spirit do glorify
Jesus for he will take of what is mine
and declare it to you all things that
the father has are mine therefore I said
that he will take of mine and declare it
to you you got it now the Father
glorifies the Son praises the son so
does the Holy Spirit the Holy Spirit
glorifies the
son John 13
31-32 John 1331 32 watch here it's going
to get
better so when he had gone out Jesus
said now the son of man is glorified and
God is glorified in him watch here if
God is glorified in Union with the son
if the son will bring God glory through
what he does on Earth God will also
glorify him in himself and glorify him
immediately who does Jesus think he is
you see Jesus what he's saying
I glorify God on Earth by fulfilling his
will and God responds by glorifying me
immediately I glorify him he glorifies
me the same way I glorify him is the
same way he glorifies me who does Jesus
think he
is John 17 veres
1-2 John 17 veres 1-2
John 17: 1- 2 watch
here Jesus spoke these words now watch
here get blown get ready to be blown
away with verse
one Jesus spoke these words lifted up
his eyes to heaven and said father the
hour has come glorify your son that your
son Also may glorify you who do you
think you are
Jesus notice the command here glorify me
so that I can glorify you
I glorify you so that you can glorify me
you glorify me so that I can glorify you
glorify me so that I respond by
glorifying you in
return which creature can speak this
this
way and then verse two what does he
say as you have given him authority over
All Flesh that he should give eternal
life to as many as you have given
him John 8:54
John
8:54 guys Focus please John
854 Jesus answered if I honor myself my
honor is nothing it is my father who
honors me of whom you say that he is
your god who does Jesus think he is the
father honors me the father glorifies me
the father Praises
me the way I glorify the father praise
the father and honor the father
now can you imagine a flesh and blood
Jew can you imagine a flesh and blood
Jew telling other Jews you know the one
that you call God you know who he is
he's my father and he honors me though
you dishonor
me can you again again I don't know if
you understand the implication of this
do you see all three persons of the
godhead pray to one another if by prayer
you mean lavishing praise and glory and
honor on the other having intimate
communion fellowship with the other all
three are engaged in
prayer that sink
in okay so that's clear yeah Jesus
praised to God meaning the father
because he's not the father just like
the father prays to Jesus and the spirit
prays to Jesus and Jesus prays to the
spirit and the spirit prays to the
father and the father prays to the
spirit exactly what would you expect
three Eternal distinct persons are
inseparable from one another who love
and adore one another who desire to
glorify and praise the other what do you
expect them to do ignore one another